in my audience.
>> Oh, is it possible that maybe I just like I'm a little
stupid. >> Uh yeah. >> Okay. [laughter]
>> Oh, you don't move. I didn't expect that one. What?
No way. Actual bomb tactic. That comes out as a draw now. Okay.
You're going to bomb yourself like that? That is a draw. Papa
Gut pulls back. It's zero zero on the board. We take the points
away from Andrew. Okay.
>> Uh, we're like two subs away for another hour and we're
going to do Papa Gut. Okay, so Papa Gut and Andrew Wilson had
a debate that went
interestingly. Okay, I heard it was pretty good. It started off
from a short that Papa Gut put out where he was on Andrew Wilson.
Okay. And Andrew Wilson responded. Let's check out the sword.
>> The short, sorry. Religious psychosis is the worst form
of mental illness, says Papa Gut. Okay. Religious psychosis is
the worst form of mental illness. Wow.
Kind of >> leftwing communities and leftwing groups, especially
online communities and online groups, really pander to the mentally
ill in a big way. I think that it's a form of weaponization.
They want to attract the extremely mentally ill into these communities.
>> Okay, we I got to do it. I'm so sorry cuz I know my
community is sick of it. You guys believe in a magical apple
curse that removed our immortality. You believe that God let
the snake, the devil's snake inside of the Garden of Eden, to
test people, Adam and Eve, who he didn't even give full agency
to. They didn't even know right from wrong. Removed their immortality.
That's what you think happened. You think that climate change
only exists when it rains for 40 days and for 40 nights one time.
What are you saying now? Once you guys >> why I just Why
>> against megaurches manipulating people who think they
have to give all their money to millionaires or else they won't
go to heaven? This is the entire mythology where you guys go,
God made all the sin in the earth and he put us in all of us
to test us. And also he birthed his son, but this time he didn't
make him out of dust like he did Adam. He put it inside of a
young girl and then he was born just so that he could die so
we could die for the sins that God put into all of us. And then
we're all supposed to get together and once a week we're supposed
to metaphorically cannibalize the body and blood of Jesus Christ.
It's like the most insanely group delusional people are sitting
here telling us that like people on the left are mentally ill.
There's nothing more mentally ill than the way that you practice
religion. And by the way, none of them like like to acknowledge
the love part where Jesus is supposed to not treat people like
subhuman. They don't acknowledge that part, but they love the
part that hates gay and trans people. Why? Because the Bible
said so. That's it. The most mentally ill people are conservative
voters who overly value religion. Believing in God can be a great
thing, but they can't separate their non-factual side, their
spiritual side from the logic of the world. And it puts them
ripe to be manipulated because what religion teaches you, the
way that they learn it is authoritarian control. The story of
Adam and Eve, what is that story? Listen to me or you will get
hurt even if you don't understand. Adam and Eve didn't have any
autonomy or agency over themselves. They didn't know right from
wrong. But they were punished either either way. It doesn't take
critical thinking. And if you're God or
>> representative of God or you say you're representative
of God, you have to be listened to regardless. That's it. But
go on about how mentally ill people cuz somebody feels like they
were born in the wrong body. >> This guy's really smart.
This this guy I'm getting the impression this guy's really smart.
>> How that's anywhere comparable to the religious psychosis
of the right. You're right, dude. I don't know. Okay, you you
got me. You got me, bro. You got me. I'M GOING TO DISOWN my kid
cuz he wants to suck up. Which is so funny because like there
are plenty of biological reasons why gay people should exist.
Oh, they can't have babies. Well, people can't have babies cuz
we're poor, right? But what do gay people do? Data shows they
spend more of their money on
Did Did he just say a biological reason?
And then he says, well, they spend money I What's the I feel
like he's um he's like going off on stuff. I I don't care already.
The way he's presented this, I >> people that aren't their
kids, whether it's their, you know, their nieces and nephews
or >> although I do hope Andrew Wilson kind of curb stomps
him now. >> It's they adopt at higher rates. So gay people
biologically exist to take care of kids that aren't quote unquote,
and I'm saying this insensitively insensitively, their own kids.
That's the whole point. That's why they would do that. That's
why if you look at it, the more boys a mother has, the higher
chance that the boys will be gay as they come out. Because there
clearly is a biological reason to create gay people in a family
structure. But you want to know what? [laughter] It's all crazy.
It's all crazy. >> Left-wing communities and leftwing groups,
especially online communities and online groups, really pander
to the mentally ill in a big way. I think that it's a form of
weaponization. They want to attract the extremely mentally ill
into these communities. >> So Andrew Wilson responds to
this and says, "Retard snipes at me endlessly, but refuses to
talk to me. only about me. Everybody is right when they are yelling
at a picture. Lol.
And that leads into a whole argument between
Pisco and Andrew Wilson. Why are you dodging me, bro? Why are
you so scared? Your eyebrows. It's your eyebrows. They're scary.
Says Rachel Wilson.
All
So, Papa Gut responds with this whole thing about Pisco. Okay.
Andrew Wilson is a debate dodging 10 IQ [__] Brian,
but I'd happily fly out. Let me know. And Andrew Wilson says,
"Just pay Pisco. Then we can debate. Lol. Too much pride." And
Andrew Wilson says he's like, "Pisco's got to give money to debate
him." Right? That's Andrew Wilson's thing for a while now is
you have to give money to a charity or to somebody I say to debate
me.
And so Papa Gut does this responds this way. We can have a conversation.
And Andrew just won't be able to pay you the $7,000 you typically
beg for. Pisco follows up. I think you'll be justified in refusing
to talk to Paleoccon
until he agrees to talk to me. Debate dodgers shouldn't accuse
others of debate dodging. Pisco tisk tisk. As long as you are
fine with me letting large platforms know you should they shouldn't
be talking to you. I'm fine with it if you are. And Pisco responds
as long as you are fine with me calling out your debate dodging
every time you call people out for debate dodging.
Do what you want. You green lit this, not me. So Andrew basically
says, uh, if you keep saying I do I dodged you, I'm going to
tell platforms not to talk to you. Huh? If you keep saying I
dodged you, I'm going to tell like a bunch of different people
I know not to talk to you. How about that? How about that,
So, do what you want. You green lit this, not me. Pisco says,
"Haha, what is this? I just find it funny that you accuse others
of debate dodging when you're the number one debate dodger. Then
prove it by paying the 4K and see if I dodge. You're way overestimating
your market value, pack of cigarettes. I mean, no. I I'm sure
a lot of creators would pay maybe not 4,000, but they'd pay a
lot of money to debate Andrew Wilson,
right?
Like it's it is still like an amount of money that is not unreasonable
to ask. It's just that he's saying it because he's trying to
little bro pisco. If if he'd been asking this for like a solid
reason or something, I wouldn't really have a problem with it.
He's just trying to little broco here. He's like trying to stand
up business and it's like, dude, just talk to the guy. It's fine.
Just talk to the guy. Then stop asking me for debates, he says.
Okay. Anyway, then we got the Papa Gut VOD. All right. Big Papa
gut versus big Papa fascist. Okay, let's go. Here it is. Here
it is. >> Hey, what's up? Yeah. So, I wanted to uh have
a chat with you about a bunch of things that you said about me
that are just fundamentally completely totally
>> And I wanted you to give an accounting forum because
I actually don't understand why you would say them. >> So,
um [clears throat] first thing I wanted to get into was this.
You said, quote, "You sit there and advocate for 19 year olds
and 18 year olds to sleep with 35year-old men."
>> Exact quote from your video. >> Which video is
that a quote from?
>> Yeah, I'll pull it up here. Hang on. >> Yeah,
sure.
>> So, you're rolling a >> That was from the Andrew
is an essay apologia basically reviewing the Oliver
>> Okay. Yeah. you were having a conversation about uh
>> I guess 35 40 year old guys dating young girls, right?
>> So, there's like a little thing going on here that I
don't know, it would be like annoying to me cuz I always find
people who do this kind of signaling like super gay, but I 100%
believe Andrew could have rolled his smoke before he started
this. He's rolling smokes now. It's like I just be like, "Hey,
you need me to give you a minute to roll those smokes? I'm going
to just finish up some content on my stream." >> That's
not >> cuz like I like what are you doing here? You're
like, you're trying to roll. You're rolling smoke. What the [__]
are you doing? It's like so gay. You're trying to signal. You're
trying to signal that you like don't respect me. Off then. We
don't have to talk. I'm good. It is a part of a performance.
It's a gay performance. And but like even acknowledging it is
it's probably meant to like annoy somebody. I find it like super
gay. I might just ignore it and like
I might literally just walk away and be like, "Hey, I'm going
to go actually grab a drink." That's probably what I'd do. You
ever chain smoked?
Uh, no. I've never chain smoked.
Nope. Never chain smoked. Never rolled my own cigarettes.
I just say if you're sitting down to talk with somebody, you
like make them wait on you intentionally. I feel like that that's
a sign of disrespect immediately.
It is. It is. Or you'd apologize, be like, "Oh, my bad. I didn't
I I meant to get this done."
That's I I just see it and I'm like, "Oh, this is a gay performance."
But Andrew is very very um intelligent about how he does his
gay performances.
So I I I would personally be like, "Yeah, I might go grab a drink
or use the bathroom or something. Just get >> Do you realize
a distinction between an advocation for a thing or me saying
that there's actually no argument that I've heard which is compelling
for why the thing bad?
>> Okay.
I sure.
I think that when I from what I remember from watching it, you
were pretty like hardline. You think it's okay and that actually
the woman benefits from the relationship. So, I would consider
that like an advocation.
>> Yeah. How's that me advocating that 18 or 19year-olds
should sleep with 35-year-old men? >> Well, you said that
they get like a lot of positive benefits out of it, right? Cuz
a 35-year-old guy has a lot of >> Some some can. >> Sure.
Why is it bad that you advocate for that?
>> Yeah. Well, wait, wait, wait. Do you realize the distinction
though between me saying or you saying Andrew saying that 18
19 year olds should sleep with 35y olds? >> Well, you said
that they get like a tremendous benefit out of it because the
guy has a lot of like money and >> Yeah. But you need to
untangle the two >> So are you saying >> that's not
a that's not an claim. That's not me saying that 19year-olds
>> should sleep with 35year-olds. Me >> we're talking
about dating. I think >> in Yeah. In particular cases,
there can be benefits to uh a 19 or 18-year-old marrying somebody
who's older. I wouldn't advocate any of them sleep with anybody
before marriage. Right. >> So, that's one. And then the
second thing is is like I've never act I've never said that they
should sleep with uh with 35 year olds. That's ridiculous.
>> Why is there just never happened?
Because that would be a should claim, a monolithic should claim.
>> Okay. Sure. Um, yeah, I think that I guess the way that
I use advocation,
>> this is already just like annoying as um
if he was like basically giving a whole bunch of good reasons
to do this and he didn't say, "But obviously you should never
have good side of marriage or something." I don't know.
It's It's like whatever. I I just don't like I super don't care.
Yeah, I was hyperbolic. Yep. I was I was hyperbolic. Uh, it's
not a universal claim you made as hyperbach.
I broadly think that you were advocating for like positive benefits
to it,
you know, but I don't think you think it's a should thing. I
don't think you're making a moral claim about 18-year-olds, 35y
olds.
>> Um, it seems proper to me. You seem to be okay with
it. That's a general advocation. It doesn't mean that you don't
advocate for similar age relationships, but it kind of seems
like we're splitting hairs
unnecessarily. >> Okay. No, no, we're not. We're not though.
So like you think that people should have access to the right
of freedom of speech? >> Yeah, sure. >> Okay. Should
they should they scream you're gay?
>> No, but if you wanted to, I'd advocate for that. >> Right.
No. Right. So that's the
>> that you you believe that? >> Well, I would I
would advocate I would advocate for your ability to scream you're
gay. >> Yeah, I get it. But but you're not saying that
I should do that. I should scream you're gay. No, but I would
say that I'm still be I would still advocate for people to scream
you're gay based on freedom of speech if that's >> No,
you're not advocating that they >> Oh god, [laughter] he's
Oh god. Well, no you wouldn't.
>> I'm advocating that if you want to speech to do it.
>> I'm advocating that if you want to scream you're gay,
then >> that's the right. That's the right. >> Oh
god. >> You should scream you're gay because it's freaking
Yeah, but do you understand the >> I need the um I need
to go get a transition that does the thing Shimu does all the
time. Shimu's here right now. He does the Kiano Reeves thing
all the time. See this Kiana Reeves meme on his timeline from
time to time. Okay, I need this as like a transition on my stream.
This stupid
>> POV, you're listening to Papa Gut speak for any length
of time and it's just this reaction right here. K Reeves screaming
over and over again. My my brain is >> the distinction
here. Like you're not saying people should go scream you're gay,
right? >> No, but I think if they want to, they I would
advocate for them to do that. >> Now you're in the same
Now you're in the same exact boat as me. I'm not saying you should
go and marry a 35year-old. I'm just explaining that if you want
to marry a 35-year-old, I don't see any good compelling arguments
why you >> Okay. So that's like the big the issue is the
uh word advocation.
>> Does he really not see any reasons why you shouldn't?
Maybe. I guess. I mean, I'm sure he doesn't really feel like
probably in his worldview, he probably just thinks like having
um like a pure relationship with your partner is not that important,
right? Like, not that it's bad, it's just not that important
to a marriage. >> It's not a word advocation. It's a distinction
in positions which gives your audience the wrong impression.
Makes it sound like I'm advocating that women at 18 should be
finding themselves 35-year-old husbands, which is insane. >> And
nothing I've ever said. And by the way, what is what would even
your issue be with that? If an 18 or 19year-old decided that
they wanted to marry a 30 or 35year-old, like let's say a 19-year-old
had two kids with a 35-year-old man that she loved. Would you
advocate that they get divorced? >> Are they twins?
>> Damn. Would she like pregnant at 17? How'd she have
two kids with a 30? >> Oh, are they are the kids twins?
I was like, they're different ages. >> Who cares? It's
irrelevant. >> I I mean, I would say it's pretty relevant
if she had kids with him at 17. That's uh I believe that would
be kind of crossing into the territory of like some kind of >> She
had her first one with him at 18 or her second one with him at
19. >> Gotcha. Okay. I was just making sure. Um I mean
when did the relationship start if they started having kids at
18?
>> Interesting. Oh, that seems like a very fast relationship.
I guess that would be uh immaturity. I'm not I'm not against
>> Would you would you
got a divorce >> No, I wouldn't advocate that they got
a >> Of course. Of course not. So you don't really have
any even moral compelling reason why this is wrong. Well, like
I said, I think it's immature, but if you want to do it, I don't
think that everything has to be a strong argument. I can look
at like a 30 >> like I think the answer should just be
like I would have a lot of red flags there in terms of how these
people would have met. What spaces were they sharing? Um what
spaces does a 35-year-old share with a with an 18-year-old where
they get become like romantically interested in each other, but
he doesn't have any, you know, power over that person where it's
not like a weird dynamic going on. You know what I mean? That's
like and especially that they wouldn't share that same space.
Any space they could share when she's 18, but not when she was
17, 16, 15, 14. Do you know what I'm saying? Like immediately
that sounds like a thing that was getting set up. But if if that's
not the case, if they somehow like met, you know, they were in
like some blind there's like a story you could come up with that
would be fine there. I would just be a little concerned about
a guy who's like 32 thinking this 15-year-old is hot and biting
his time. >> 5-year-old person dating an 18-year-old person
like, "Oh, that's immature. There's a big difference in life
experience, but like if you want to do it, you're an adult. Be
my guest. >> Yeah. So, what's even the issue with me advocating?
If I were advocating for what would even be the issue? >> Well,
you came in here like seeming to have a very negative association
with the word advocation. So, I don't necessarily see like a
huge issue. I'm pretty sure I also >> have a negative.
>> I'm pretty sure I also said this. >> There's no
negative. There's no negative uh with the word advocation. I'm
untangling the position of you can believe in the first amendment
but not make a should claim that you should yell you're gay because
>> but you should be able to Yeah. But I would advocate
that you would be able to do that >> in the same way that
you were advocating that people should be able >> Now you're
getting it. Yeah. They should be able to not that they should
only that they should be able to. Right. But that's a huge difference
right? Huge >> Um I guess but it doesn't change that it's
still advocation right? I don't >> Okay. Yeah. So Sophia,
my question would be on a college campus like how would these
two meet in a way that like is very likely but doesn't represent
any possible issues. Now even if they have issues there could
be a relationship. I'm just
>> but do you understand how that is? It's like no
if you advocate for one thing that means you advocate for another
thing. >> I don't really understand the correlation. Simply
what I said is that if you're okay or you were you you were advocating
right for like an 18-year-old to be able to date or marry a 35-year-old
in the same way that I >> different than advocating that
they
>> Did I say the word? So the issue isn't the word advocate.
The issue is the word
>> I claim that I'm saying you're saying that I I shouldn't
have said should. I should have said should be able to.
>> Yeah. Otherwise what you're do you're >> So we
weren't So I just want to be clear. We weren't having an issue
with the word advocacy. We're having an issue with the word should
versus should be able to. >> Yeah, we're having an issue
with you attributing claims to me. I don't make >> Okay.
Well, I just wanted to make sure cuz I thought the issue was
advocation. That's the sense that you made me feel. But sounds
like I should have said should be able to
advocate should >> I
this very funny to me because
how did how did Papa Gut go this entire time on the internet
where he like has conversations with people? Like I've never
taken a philosophy class. I've barely even watched any philosophy
videos. I don't really know philosophy at all. I'm still extremely
extremely extremely like neoight in any understanding of philosophy.
Okay. And I know what like a moral claim is like a should claim
like an ought claim.
I don't know how you end up in these spaces in any of these like
liberal adjacent spaces and you like debate spaces. You talk
about politics. How do you even have those kinds of conversations
if you don't know this? Like particularly what I was told was
this guy used to watch a ton of Destiny. How do you watch a ton
of Destiny and not know this?
There's like table stakes for even understanding the conversations,
Like I actually I actually don't get it. I don't get how you
could not understand what Andrew is saying here.
Be able to >> And do you know why you should do that?
>> well why I think you should do that >> Why is
that? Because then I think that when you make justifications
to your audience, you're just going to be like, "Well, I actually
agree with him."
>> What? What do you mean?
>> Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. So, you're saying that I'm lying
to try to make people hate you? >> Do I think Andrew would
say it's a it's moral like a moral good to for an 18-year-old
to a 35-year-old? No. Because he just said he didn't make that
claim. And if he believes that you ought to do it, and he says
it's a moral good, you ought do moral goods. Obviously, >> in
my audience, >> yeah. Oh, is it possible that maybe I just
like I'm a little stupid?
>> Uh, yeah. Okay. [laughter]
Oh, you don't move. I DIDN'T EXPECT THAT ONE. What [laughter]
is it possible that I'm just a
Yes. Oh, well, there you go. No way. Actual bomb tactic. That
comes out as a draw now. Okay. You're going to bomb yourself
like that? That is a draw. Papa Gut pulls back. It's 000 on the
board. We take the points away from Andrew. >> So why it's
possible? >> Why instantly go to like >> you only
you only get one of those things. You only get one. >> Bad
faith though >> because of the malicious fact that you
do it multiple times. You do it all the time. I have tons of
examples. That's just the first one. >> So that's just
the first example. >> I see. So is it possible? Now you
could say malicious. I think there's something to be said. And
Andrew is more careful with his words because of um
because of how like the space he operates in. He's constantly
worried about somebody clipping him and using it against him,
right? No, no, no. The read is that Papa Gut is very often not
careful with his words. He's going to call it malicious because
probably if somebody's
um is is consistently reckless with their words such that they
paint a totally fake fake picture of you in their audience's
mind, you're going to call them malicious rather like regardless
of whether they're doing it intentionally or not like with the
intent to like lie about you or if they're just intentionally
harming you with without understanding that they're doing it
by lying, right? That's that's probably where he's coming from.
And by the way, uh, on that whole thing with Oliver, you know
for sure that I was not advocating for essay. Like you know that
for sure. >> Oh, this is like a while ago. Okay. I think
I'm trying to remember what you said because I think I reacted
to your
Um, you want to give me a refresher on it because I think there
was more context to it, right?
>> Yeah. He was making monolithic all
The reason the reason that you can't use an argument from outlier
is because if you agree that X is possible, then I can always
point to that as an outlier and gave him a jarring position for
a potential outlier, which he agreed with. >> Then he dishonestly
clipped that as though I wasn't mocking him for his stupidity,
but rather advocating for that position. You did not make that
clear for your audience at all. >> So what you're I think
with the Oh, wait. That's
kind of similar to what just happened with Caseyron, right? Didn't
we just watch that happen with Caseyron like 90 seconds before
this whole thing where he basically took what was her like satirizing
satarizing a position and then basically represented it to his
audience as her position.
Luckily for Papa God, I do think odds are good his audience is
at least smarter than him and could probably see that he's that
up. claim was was that um you said there might be some people
who enjoy salt and you weren't saying that. Hold on, let me from
what I remember and you weren't saying that that makes it justifiable.
You were saying something along the lines that just because some
people might enjoy it doesn't mean that is good. That's from
what I remember from the full context, right? >> Yeah.
It's actually it's actually uh not
>> So [clears throat] if you say all people are stupid
Yeah. >> you agree with me that that's a stupid claim to
make, right? >> Sure. Yeah. >> Okay. Now, if I if
if there was a response to that, well, no, some people aren't
stupid, right? Or some people aren't this or some people aren't
that. >> If you're trying to use an argument from
>> So, all I'm pointing out there is if you're only going
to use arguments from outliers when we're talking in generalities,
then you have to be prepared for the fact that I could use whatever
outlier that I wanted to as long as it falls under the purview
of logical possibility. I think the outlier thing, so the example
would be that that would be harmful by and large, right? What
is the outlier thing? Like the the all people are dumb. There's
probably not a terrible harm, like a horrible harm being done
by saying, well, no, some people aren't dumb, right? Whereas
if you're like, well, actually, we should make a rule against
because some people like it being raped, then the potential harm
there is really high. >> Now, I can send you the clip of
Oliver saying, of course, it's logically possible that this could
occur. >> Yeah. Yeah. But I already mocking him. That was
me mocking him for that. >> Right. Right. Well, I don't
need to. >> How is that? How is that apologia?
>> Well, so just to be clear, I think I just conceded to
that, right? Like the full context was that you said just because
in some instances. So, um I guess I'd have to retract that one.
But I remember watching your response to that and I found it
interesting that you said that there is sometimes like a Okay,
now hold on. Now I do have to see. Apparently, I got given a
clip here in the Discord of Papa Gut, good old Papa, saying that
both Destiny and Andrew are. And I'm guessing that's going to
be along the exact same lines, one to one,
dude. Stupid [__] Hold on. This This needs music
when we pull it up. This needs music.
Raise your hands together
>> who is that? Hard to say. Hard to say. Hard to say.
Difficult to know. Really?
Difficult to know. Okay, hold on. I need to pull this clip up.
Give me a second. What was this from? [gasps] >> Why do
people ignore that Destiny's of revenge? I mean, like, yeah,
he was. You got Listen, man. Let's not be like a dishonest [__]
here.
All right. And I'm happy he's on the upswing. I want him to stop
around. you know, the whole like I think unintentionally having
pretty crazy to me. Um, I'm being charitable. He's made a lot
of dumb remarks in the past. He's a degenerate. He hasn't really
changed. Like, he hasn't really matured. I want to like >> Like,
this isn't this isn't the clip that I wanted. >> I want
to be bad faith. >> Oh, I think he could be very valuable,
especially against these weirdos like Andrew. Um, >> oh,
hold on. >> And like Destiny is held to a higher standard.
Like Andrew Andrew basically admitted that he thinks that 17-year-old
girls are adults and probably 16. Like Andrew thinks that like
because biblically girls are adults when like they look mature
enough. And so Andrew is okay with like child abuse. I guess
you'd say teenager abuse like 16 and 17 he would be fine with.
You could probably get him to say that's
>> I mean
there is another thing here where it's like yeah but also
there are definitely states and definitely countries like Canada.
Okay. Like Canada
that the I mean the age of consent is literally 16. So, you know,
like
it's obvious that like society hasn't caught up with with where
Papa is. I think I don't I wouldn't mind if the age of consent
was just 18 blanket for anybody above the age of like 20. Like
the like I I think that would be better. You know what I'm saying?
But it's not like it needs to we're all rushing out to change
it. It's just generally society frowned upon enough that
that people don't do it. 15y olds are mature enough to be married
to like 40y olds. Andrew would concede to that. I could already
tell. [snorts] Um right. So like you know Destiny unintentionally
having potentially I guess see material of a 17-year-old girl
which again I don't think he knew about. Um like
Andrew Wilson wouldn't care cuz he probably is okay with kids
like teenagers getting like by adults and him thinking that that's
actually a beneficial relationship.
I can see why Andrew is um kind of annoyed about this when Papa
got Papa got saying this stuff and he's signaling he doesn't
really have like any foundation to be saying these things at
all.
I I can see why Andrew would get frustrated. Not because he's
like that Papa Gut's like way out to lunch on this. He's probably
saying some things that are somewhat true, but you can tell he
doesn't really know how to express what he's feeling. He's just
kind of saying stuff. You know, I just, you know, I don't think
that like if you look at Destiny, I don't think the people like
he got like he just needs like I don't know, maybe he is like
a little more mature. You know what I mean? I feel like five
years ago he was, you know, he gives off a similar energy.
>> I say probably like the insane doxing and harassment
campaigns were a little beyond just being a little immature.
But, you know, wouldn't expect Papa to stay a breast of the current
situation. of you outrageous things and then getting attention
and then having to
um square it up. Um do you think that that's an issue that you
constantly say outrageous things sometimes possibly for attention
then people misconrue you and you don't correct the behavior?
>> What do I say that's outrageous? >> That's just
what you had said in your response video that you >> what
I said in a response video is that >> is that you will
routinely say things that are outrageous. >> I use examples.
Yeah. Sometimes I'll use examples which are jarring. They're
not outrageous. They're jarring >> but they're not out
there's nothing outrageous about it. using a >> the thing
about like morally confounding questions is they are very effective
in delivering your point because people when you when you basically
say okay here's a thing you're saying now if I raise the stakes
on the thing you're saying so you actually care about some aspect
of it here's how it will change your mind right
did Papa criticize you why you going so hard at him
he just says a lot of really dumb things I keep getting clips
of him saying really dumb things I know he disagrees with me
on some fairly major issues as well so I kind assume he wasn't
that like he wasn't somebody I was going to agree or get along
with. And then the like couple clips I've watched recently, it's
just very painful. Caleb Hammer thing was very painful.
It's very painful to watch. >> An example that's uncomfortable.
It may be jarring, but the thing is is like even if that was
the case, let's just say it was you consider it to be outrageous
that I use this as an example for outliers. Well, how's that
defensible that somebody clips it up dishonestly and spreads
it as though I'm in favor of essay? >> Well, I don't think
it would be. Um, I will say that you also have like another take
and maybe it's out of context, but you were talking about what
was it force doctrine and that you said that women should be
to some extent like apologetic or happy that men don't them.
That doesn't really seem like >> oh lord. >> I don't
understand
what's wouldn't that also be uh some kind of >> Yeah. No,
the ideal No, it's the opposite. the ideal from feminists.
So feminists operate under a worldview
>> and that that worldview that they operate under is very
secular and seriously agnostic towards God. Do you
>> do Horse doctrine again? Horse doctrine again. Now hold
on. I sent Aaron the thumbnail from Andrew's video which is very
funny. Give me a second. You see the thumbnail for Aaron's video.
This didn't even happen. They they said they they basically this
is malicious. Andrew
straight raid never loses frame in the entire video and you're
painting her as somebody who like lost frame. Okay. Actually
malicious. Totally malicious.
Was that white woman? It's supposed to be straight raid. It's
literally a like an AIed clip of straight or an AI picture of
straight raid. Thumbnails are clickbait. But I just I think it's
funny when you basically when you take something that didn't
exist and make it exist. I thought it was funny. I mean it it
is what it is, right?
I'm sure Andrew Wilson wouldn't feel the need to criticize somebody
who like put him in a thumbnail crying if they like AI a photo
of him crying,
you know, or raging out and turning totally red. They he he couldn't
be mad about that, right?
Is this the meta? It is the meta. Who am I Who am I to criticize
when uh Riyle's out here doing thumbnails like this, okay, with
my content? Who am I to criticize when Riyle's out here making
this like Emir thumbnail?
This really is the same thing, is it not? Is this not just the
exact same concept?
We We all know that this isn't real, but Riyle made it anyway.
Okay,
so
I I really shouldn't be throwing stones in glassouses, should
I?
Same concept when you think about it. Okay,
same concept. >> Agree with that. >> Uh, maybe. I
guess so. I mean, why would it be agnostic towards God? Is it
cuz like the woman has some kind of like Because generally generally
if you follow an Abraham religion, the Abrahamic religion, they're
patriarchal.
>> So feminists want to destroy the patriarchy then necessarily
>> they tend to stay away from Abra. >> So you're
saying that like if a woman wants to have like be seen uh or
have an equal role as a man that would be in or counterintuitive
to religion.
>> Well an equal role in what way? >> Depends on
the way. uh just in the same being able to work and I guess lead
a household or have an equal contribu contribution to leading
a household.
>> Well, no, that would depend on >> Okay. Okay.
>> So, the thing the thing is is like that's not what we
mean by a patriarchal religion. It means that the the body or
the the head of the religion. >> Oh, also uh what do we
need? We probably need at least another hour here, guys. Probably
need at least another hour. If you guys like the content, go
ahead, sub, donate however you can. All right. appreciate all
the support. I've not been shilling a lot recently. I got to
go back to shilling every hour. I'm really I'm really took took
my foot off the gas in terms of shilling. I really need to shill
more because it's not that people don't want to donate or they
can't donate. It's that I don't even remind them and then they
just get into the stream. They're way too engaged. They're way
too focused. Okay. And then they just forget. That's my fault.
All right. That's my fault. >> Is going to be male necessarily.
Like women can't preach. They can't have positions of authority
over men inside the church. It's necessarily patriarchal. Okay.
>> So, your goal is to dismantle patriarchy. Obviously,
you're going to be steering clear of Abrahamic >> Okay.
Yeah. So, like the feminism is counterintuitive to religion because
it advocates that women have like the ability to be equal in
all ways to men, >> even including within the church, right?
Or even if they didn't think that that you need >> Well,
no, even outside the church. I don't be trying to dismantle the
patriarch the patriarchal nature of the >> I don't usually
see a lot of feminism that's like specifically religious related.
So, maybe there's something I'm not seeing. But like generally
speaking, it seems like you're saying that because feminism advocates
for women to be equal to men, it's against religion because religion
is supposed to put men I mean maybe you wouldn't say higher than
women but like in a different classification as women. >> No,
the point of the point No, the point the point of feminism is
to dismantle dismantle patriarchal systems.
>> That's the point. So there's an oppressor oppressed
class. >> If women are the oppressed class, then who's
the oppressor class? It's men. >> I'll be honest. If I
could skip past the entire force doctrine portion, I would >> I
would actually skip past everything in force doctrine right now.
>> Latigious Gamer, thank you very much. I don't know if
there's going to be anything interesting here for force doctrine
conversation. >> It basically is never it's like never
good. Latigious Gamer, I believe that was one set that double
reported, but thank you very much for the five gifted. Very appreciated.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. >> Sure. Right. I guess.
>> Yeah, it has to. It has to be. That's the deduction.
Who are women? Women aren't being oppressed by women. and they're
being oppressed by men, right? So, that's the patriarch. >> I'm
going to try it. I usually don't like skipping ahead because
I don't I just don't like skipping ahead. Okay. I usually like
just watching as one contiguous piece, but I can't do
I can't do force doctrine for the 80th time in like a week. And
by the 80th, I mean the second time in a week, okay? It's like
the whole convo. If you have um some kind of organizations that
that is necessarily patriarchal mind, in this >> the church
is going to be necessarily patriarchal, they're going to want
to dismantle the elements of that that make it patriarchal. >> So,
do you have like an issue with women wanting to work and get
equal pay or work similar towards the same jobs as men? Or is
this just because >> women have always worked? That's like
equal jobs like should men be like C I'm just trying to flesh
you out. Like are should we be able to be CEOs or anything like
that? Is there any restriction that >> I don't care. It's
completely >> Oh, so then what would that be negative toward?
I've never seen feminism that actively is negative towards
um religion. So I don't really I don't see how these two things
can't exist. No, I really don't. So you don't see you don't see
feminism. >> I would say religion is antagonistic to feminism
and it's likewise antagonistic back
right like the at least in the in America maybe I don't know
about like other you know North America it tends to be people
arguing from a religious lens on why women should be um like
why you know abortion laws should be the way they are. I would
say abortion is one of the things universal access to abortion
and birth control are one of are probably the things that have
like sort of taken women out of the household most like allowed
women to determine their own futures that they don't aren't immediately
beholden to raising a kid the second they have
right
I think that's universally agreed upon more or less that women
have the ability to like opt out and continue on with a career
path that's like really really important
right and so I do think religion's been the biggest opposition
to that I
That's that's my understanding movements which are trying to
get like female priests and female preachers and yeah like the
Catholic Church they've been fighting that for 100 years the
massive movement towards getting females who are in positions
of power and authority >> not in the church it's really
not something I I mean I trust that it's happening from whatever
sphere you're you're existing >> it's been happening in
the Orthodox church and it happens in all Protestant churches
and >> are you okay with feminism outside of the church
then or is it just inside the >> all femin all feminism
bad >> okay gotcha so why if it's like putting the church
part aside is because it's >> It's an illogical position.
It's you in order to deconstruct patriarchy, you have to appeal
to the patriarchy.
>> What do you mean? >> It's necessarily circular.
>> Well, how are women going to overthrow the patriarchy
without appealing to the >> I maybe we have a different
I mean a different understanding of feminism because when I see
feminism, it's not explicitly about overthrowing a patriarchy
and it's more just about women having the ability. >> I
I also think this is probably a poor that's not circular, right?
having to appeal to something to destroy it is not circ like
incorrect because it's
If they pass I don't know. It seems pretty obvious that you could
use a system to destroy it. Oh, hold on. The same way the abolition
of slavery did. Yeah. Well, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure. I'm
just saying Andrew says a lot of things that like I I don't know
why people don't take these trap doors out of conversations that
it seemed to exist to me, but I I haven't thought through like
the next, you know, five lines of dialogue that are going to
come out. If you say why why is it inherently wrong to use a
system to destroy that system
or destroy some aspect of a system, it doesn't seem like it would
be that wrong, right? It doesn't seem like it would be incorrect
or impossible. I don't know why he's saying that's a contradiction.
You can't appeal to the patriarchy to destroy the patriarchy.
Yeah, you could
>> to work and get divorced and things of that nature so
they can have an equal footing to a man because they have >> What's
the difference between feminism and liberalism? >> I don't
know. You don't know? >> They're just the same thing. >> Sure.
I mean, I don't really know what liberalism is. >> Sure.
[laughter] >> No, they're distinct ideologies. Okay. The
purpose of feminism is deconstruct.
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. Sing with me this Christmas melody.
Dance to the beat. Wave your hands together. Come feel the heat
forever and forever.
>> Thank you, Ruben. Ruben, thank you for the three.
I should have put this up while the message was playing, but
thank you so much. oppressor class. >> Okay. And you don't
consider an oppressor class. >> Every single definition
you could pull up right now of feminism is going to include deconstructing
patriarchy. >> Okay. So, you don't like feminism
>> Oh, that's really slimy of him that literally him and
Aaron were at the same debate. They pulled it up with Google.
It didn't include that thing. And then Andrew asked her to include
it. He's literally just lying. He literally had this disproven
to him last week. >> Oh boy.
>> That is a little weird. [laughter]
And you think that patriarchy is a good >> No, I don't
even think it's possible. I think it's an irrational It's an
irrational position.
>> Okay. Why >> you can't? Because you're appealing
to the very same thing that you're trying to overthrow to overthrow
it, which means you're necessarily going to always be appealing
to the thing to overthrow the thing because you don't have the
requisite force to overthrow it >> What's the thing? What
are they appealing to? >> The patriarchy. >> So,
the issue with feminism is that they appeal to patriarchy to
overthrow the
>> What does that look like? >> Well, okay. So, like
let's take the Middle East for instance. Mhm. >> When when
Middle Easterners tell women that they don't have any rights,
do women have rights anymore.
>> When they just tell them, I mean, I don't It seems like
they have an oppressive structure that takes away their rights.
>> Does seem like that, doesn't it? >> What What
can women do about that? Nothing. Right. >> Right. Okay.
So, you're saying that they need the patriarchy to fight against
the patriarchy and so it always exists.
>> Yeah. I just So, I again, I hate to say it, but yes,
I brought this up the other day and Solomon Sloth just brought
it up. It's like black people in America. I'm even going to not
be offensive, okay? I'm not going to I'm going to say black people
in America
did they didn't have the strength to overthrow slavery. They
didn't have the the strength to rise up and and get slavery undone
by themselves. Does that mean that it was a mistake to get rid
of slavery or that slavery has not been undone in some way? It
seems like they had to appeal to their oppressors to undo their
oppression to to let them rise above that oppression. Yeah. I
just >> necessarily appealing to the patriarchy over and
over and over and over and over >> Do you think they're
right? And technically
technically black people probably collectively wouldn't have
the force to stop themselves from being enslaved again. I'm not
saying that's a good thing. I'm saying that like population-wise
in the US if suddenly every race decided well actually probably
every race maybe except white people might be able to get away
with this. But pretty much every any race in the US if they just
decided, hey, open ball game. We're all trying to enslave each
other now. There's a very good chance that there would be groups
of people who could just totally be enslaved. Right.
So like I don't it's like just going to be the stronger group
that enslaves the other group. That doesn't mean that while that
group is very strong if they could be appealed to to overthrow
or to undo that again that that wouldn't be a good thing or wouldn't
result in something positive. You need the rest of the world
to go with it. Probably not. >> They're trying to dismantle
they're trying to dismantle the thing by appealing to the thing
to dismantle the thing in an infinite regress. >> But it
seems to work at least better in the United States or other western
countries and eastern countries. So it seems like it's working
>> as long as the So all you're saying is that the patriarchy
is benevolent. >> Yeah. Yeah, as long as I guess men are
benevolent as long as >> Yeah, that's right. [clears throat]
Doesn't it seem like you should be a little bit thankful for
the benevolence of men then? >> I guess so. Yeah. Well,
wouldn't it be But wouldn't it be men that >> Why are you
Why are you giving up the whole argument right now? >> Put
them in position in the first place. >> So, you're being
benevolent or you're being faithful. Well, hold on. Wouldn't
Wouldn't men in general? Cuz I don't think that every man alive
is a creator of patriarchy. I think it's ridiculous to blame
all >> So, I just want you to say right now, Andrew, that
black people should be thankful we don't enslave them again.
Andrew, can we get that on the record? Black people really need
to just think about thanking white people. Shouldn't you be a
little thankful that white people built this country for you
and and throw your shackles off black people? He probably would
say it. That's the funny thing. >> Men for patriarchy.
I think that's just stupid. But historically, it's men who created
the patriarchy. So why would you need to be like super thankful
to the group of people who created the
>> Because if you're a feminist and you have no morality,
no structured morality and rights are just social constructs
and all of these things are just products of the mind, then malevolence
and benevolence has no grounding. So you're just basically you
have no there's no position from which you can critique the malevolence
of the patriarchy uh or the benevolence of the patriarchy. So
if men want to oppress women from the feminist worldview they
[clears throat] have no position from which to criticize them
except well we just prefer that you don't. And if men say oh
we just prefer that we do what's their grounding then dude what
are they what what are they going to appeal to >> Well
it sounds like we're getting more into a conversation about some
kind of objective morality rather than getting into a conversation
about whether it's effective because it has been effective in
the United States. Forget aboutity. Let's just say it doesn't
exist. It's >> Let's just say that all morality is
>> Then who's the subject? You. Right. >> Okay. Sure.
>> Okay. So, if you're the subject and I'm the subject
and I want to punish you for whatever particular reason I want,
what makes me less right than you? >> Uh oh. Is it going
to be like a force doctrine thing? Cuz like I could physically
stop you from punishing me or something. Is that the is that
what you're looking for? >> Cuz it seems like we're getting
very overly complicated on the conversations or women. >> Not
overly complex. >> I think so. I think that the simplified
version of this is like, hey, women want access to more uh rights
and some kind of equal rights to be on a more equal footing so
that [clears throat] they don't have to be put into positions
of being abused by men. >> Because they prefer them >> prefer
equal rights.
>> I guess. Yeah. To the alter. >> So what if men
don't prefer to give it to them? Why are those men wrong? >> Then
I guess we'd be in the Middle East. >> Yeah. But why are
those men wrong if they don't want to? >> Why are they
right if they want to be able to? >> Yeah, that's answering
question with a question. Answer the question, then ask the question.
>> Oh, okay. That's is fair. Um I think that society is
is functions more healthily when men and women both have an equal
say in pretty much every
>> Yeah. But you see how that just goes back to preference.
I'm the subject, right? >> But why why is your preference
better than my preference?
>> Yeah, that's my question to you. Why is your preference
better than my my preference? Why? >> Uh I think that just
makes more sense
>> ah this is where we get to divine command. Okay. At
worst
everything is subjective. Everything is just your preference.
Why is your preference better than my preference? And then people
are like, "Well, your preference is dictated by God." And Andrew
is like, "Well, your your preference is just your preference."
So, at at worst, we think the same thing. Don't worry about where
my preference comes from. He's going to do that. Every there's
that one, there's that one, and force doctrine, or every single
people into a position. When you have one class of people with
a higher amount of power over another, it very quickly can lead
to abuse, whether it's men or women having a higher class. >> Yeah.
But see, see, we're back to that just that's circular. It just
goes back to if men are abusing women, why is that bad? because
they're getting hurt. Abuse usually hurts people. >> Yeah.
So, why is that bad though? >> I don't think that we should
hurt >> Yeah. Exactly. Me, I don't think we should do that.
So, you just back the preference again. >> Okay. So, you
think that being hurt is preferable or okay for women. >> I
think that I think that if your morality boils down to preference
than you just saying, I prefer this and me saying, "Well, I prefer
that I do this
basis for which to say that I'm wrong." >> I have my morality
just boils down to, I guess, like fundamentally treating people
with respect. I don't know. And uh, you know, not abusing people.
>> the appeal to daddy response for religious people is
always hilarious. Well, again, he just says that
he basically he grants you that the appeal to God is just him
masking his preference. He just says, "Yeah, it is just me masking
my preference, but then it's just we're having like uh combating
He he never says like, "I'm right because God says so." That
there'd be no point in engaging in the debate space if he did
that. >> It's my preference. What's So we're getting So
like I said like a couple minutes ago, we're getting into a conversation
about objective morality. Why don't we just go there? >> We
already are there. >> Oh, okay. >> There's no reason
to justify objective morality. If it's the case that morality
is a is subject, meaning subject to you, why would I ever need
to justify anything besides fine? Then I'll just use force to
do whatever I want because I'm the subject. >> Are you
saying that's okay or under a subjectivist worldview? Yeah, it'd
be fine. I'm the subject. >> Okay. All right. Well, I guess
there'd have to be enough people who disagreed with you to want
to counter against that. Is that foundation of America though,
right? So then, so then by that same logic, as long as there's
enough people who say no, then I'm right. >> Unfortunately,
that would be how it would work. Yeah. But hopefully we don't
get to that. >> Yeah. Right. So >> I mean, we're
in a constant like battle of opinions and ideas, right? That's
how >> do you see why that's not a tenable? Do you see
why that's not a tenable
>> Because if that's the case, then any critique that you
have of any of the
>> See you later, Koko. So I guess in this case, no, Papa
Gut's basically entertaining this. In this case, I'm trying to
think like all states should be that anytime you are outside
of a majority population, you should try to get to somewhere
where you are in the majority population. You should be in some
majority identity group that can always be able to oppress others
because oppression will always happen, right? And that like there's
probably some argument for the liberal worldview in having like
a
balanced take on this
such that you like optimize growth, optimize like technological
advancement in the civilization,
right? I'm trying to think of like how you'd explain it because
basically if you if you lean too much into this that the might
makes right idea because he's saying force doctrine is just ultimately
might makes right and it's like that's true
but then you you basically use your might to bootstrap a world
where might doesn't make right where you try to have you try
to appeal to some other things and it's like technically you
can always go back to might makes right but that that infinite
regress always happens so long as you're the weaker group in
any space. This is a gay nothing statement. They're the same
thing.
They're the exact same thing. We're saying the same thing. Yeah,
we're just saying the same thing. You say Mike makes it's the
same statement. But I I do believe there's a whole point about
bootstrapping something that where you can guarantee the rights
of other people and take advantage of their productivity, right?
You make it worthwhile for them to add their productivity to
the group so that they can so that you can build something together.
Otherwise, it's just you using force to force them to do stuff
and that's inherently less effective in most cases or at least
it has been for the past what 100 years, 150 years. You can incentivize
them economically to put their to put their input into some greater
collective that's usually been better. If you consider men do
to women which are malevolent is just a matter of subject to
the subject. The woman says no I don't like this therefore it's
wrong. The man says no I do like this therefore it's right. How
do we define or decide who's correct there without appealing
to the masses?
>> That's communism. That's not communism. That's literally
liberalism.
Communism would just be using force again. It would be way it'd
be leaning towards using force to get people to add their productivity
to the group. Liberalism would be using incentives to make it
worthwhile. You create a world where they aren't forced where
the the benefits of adding their their productivity to the group
would be like they they would incentivize them to do that. That's
the general belief, right? Is that incentives do a way better
job than forcing someone to do it. That that's why the Soviet
Well, one of the reasons the Soviet Union failed is people just
didn't have any commitment to their work because they make the
same amount as anybody else no matter how much work they put
in. >> Because if the masses agree with me that I can abuse
my wife, then I'm morally correct. And if the masses believe
that I should not abuse my wife, then I'm morally incorrect.
>> That's how it is. Yeah.
>> Can incentive or can using might to make be in fact
wrong?
Yes. Uh well, only in that If you only use might to make and
you never think of a way to basically make yourself better, eventually
somebody mightier will come
And so you you use might to make until you're raped. Unless you
can figure out a way to get people to follow you without having
to use might to get them to follow you, I think is the general
>> You have to appeal to the masses of people if you want
to live in a society. Yeah. Unfortunately. >> So morality
is subject to the masses. So if that's the case, my friend, then
if the masses say that you should be able to sleep with girls
who are 12 or 13 or 14, you actually have no moral argument that
you can make against that. Now, >> well, I do have a moral
argument for me personally. No, you don't. I do. >> You
just said that your personal morality is subject to the masses.
>> Yeah. Well, no. What I said is that my I didn't say
my personal and if I did insinuate, that's not what I meant.
What I said is that like societal morality, unfortunately, is
going to be subject to the masses. I can have a personal I can
have a personal morality and I can advocate for that morality
and I can try to use different things to uh get people to understand
why I think and why they would think by extension we should have
that type of a morality like for instance we shouldn't sleep
with 12-year-olds cuz their children still >> then you're
the ultimate arbiter of >> no we would all be the ultimate
arbiter I'm would exist in a society of adaptation but do you
understand that we all could not it's not possible for all of
us to be the ultimate arbiter of morality there would have to
be one arbiter of morality or no >> but that would be counterintuitive
to like a democracy or a democratic republic right we're not
there's no I guess you'd say the president Like we >> I
think this is where Andrew goes to well you can't have flexible
morality that changes over time. Things have to be right or wrong.
It's why divine command works that basically the if it's just
the collective it's cuz you can argue for a collective. It's
weird that he's saying no. But he's he's trying to say that like
if if you want to say the collective which is just liberalism
again the collective preferences of society with the arguments
people make that's like what is right and wrong. It's why we've
gone from thinking it was okay to [__] 13y olds as
a 40-year-old man to thinking it's like probably not good as
a society right or I wouldn't say this good but it it it can
happen was the general societal thought right morality
moves forward progresses but I think Andrew is arguing I think
that's the argument you usually hear from religious people is
that it's actually just you know tomorrow if society disc decided
that being gay was gross then you'd have to agree that being
gay is gross right like if if people broadly just believe that
being gay was wrong and you shouldn't do it, then we would just
move backwards.
>> That's possible. >> Have the ability to cast our
vote which contributes to our morality. >> But now you
have a separate Now you have a separate problem. If we as a democracy
decide you can marry 13-year-olds, you still would say that's
wrong.
>> What would make that wrong?
>> That was wrong. >> Yeah. What would what would
make it wrong other than your preference? >> Right. That
would have a conversation about how it's 13-year-olds would be
>> they don't care about your conversation. They think
they But don't they have a Don't they do don't they? No, that's
how the world has always democratic. If democratically they decide
you can marry 13-year-olds, Papa Gut says, "No, you can't. That's
against my preferences." What makes you right and all of them
>> What makes you morally correct and all of them morally
incorrect? >> I think it's wrong. Right. So that's what
I'm going to keep saying and we're going to keep dancing around.
We're going to keep dancing around this idea. >> Well,
it's morality, right? So it's wrong because you think it's wrong.
I think it's wrong with a lot of people. >> It's weird
that he knows that it's an objective morality conversation given
the whole problem with should right off the bat. Like I do actually
think he was playing dumb off the bat cuz now he like is he quickly
identifies that he is in a like conversation about objective
morality that there is no objective morality, right? >> Well,
no, it's wrong. Well, I don't have like me thinking something's
wrong doesn't change legislation, right? So like me thinking
>> we're not talking about legislation. We're talking about
>> when you say ultimate orbiter that's >> so if
if legislators get together okay and like 80% of the people agree
with him actually you know what let's make it super easy 99.99999%
only you disagree with him >> all the rest of them think
that marrying 13-year-olds is fine >> you would >> if
you're a liberal you have to accept this is a bullet you bite
as a liberal that if everybody says that it's fine you say okay
well I'm probably the person who's not understanding I'm probably
the person who has to respect the preferences of everybody body
around me. I probably do have to let you [__] that
13-year-old now, right? You just have to bite. You just bite
this bullet. You're just like, "Yeah, if everybody says it's
right, like we're not anywhere close to that world, but if everybody
said it was right, then I can't disagree with that." Like, under
my own object to that, right? >> Yeah. Well, didn't society
used to be like that until we implemented moral. >> You
would still object to that, right? >> Yeah. But didn't
we used to have a >> So, if you would still object to that,
what would make your objection moral >> and all of them
immoral?
>> I think that the 13-year-old shouldn't be marrying adults.
And then I would have a I mean you want to go in depth? I think
you understand why 13-year-olds should be married. >> No,
I I don't understand from your view what would make your position
moral and all of their positions immoral. >> Well, I would
say that Okay. I'm assuming that you're doing like a debate thing.
Like you're doing a debate thing. >> It's not a debate
thing. Question. >> I don't think it is a legitimate question.
I think that we're dancing around this. I think that we're dancing
around this idea like you have an >> We're right at the
heart. We're right at the heart of it. If it's the case that
you believe all everybody else is wrong and that they all say
marrying 13-year-olds is fine. Yeah. >> Right. Why are
you morally correct and all of them are morally incorrect? >> Because
13-year-olds aren't old enough to consent. They don't have like
a developed brain. >> That doesn't tell me why.
>> No, it does. But it does start. Yes, it does. What are
you talking about? Why
>> I mean, and they'll say, so that's a
>> But like [laughter]
you pretty quickly get to the point where it's like, oh, you
know, some disease exists that affects people who are in their
30s and blah blah blah blah blah. people can't have that many
kids. Population is dying. Actually, now as soon as people are
fertile, you actually need to start having kids as a matter of
the survival of the human race. Suddenly, the fact that their
brain don't work so good is not really at the top of the list
of things you need to consider,
I'm assuming. Right.
consensus. Well, it's it's what you have to admit to because
you literally there was a society that we are all downstream
of that existed this way,
>> right?
It's you have to you just have to agree to this anyway. >> Why why
is it why are my reasons why are my reasons not a contribution
to why I'm really bad? >> They don't believe because they
believe that it's fine regardless of if they can consent or not.
>> They think it's moral and you think it's then I would
have a conversation. I would express
>> no obligation to carry it on. Um, I don't think you
think that. I I do think you have a obligation to propagate your
like humanity. I don't think I don't think you say that ever.
Hey, if somebody can push a button and and and make sure all
of humanity doesn't get hit by an asteroid and wiped out entirely,
well, there's no like real they're not morally, you know, they're
not morally required to press the button. Shut the [__]
up.
>> My opinion. >> Yeah. And they say, >> "Go
somewhere else. Go hang out somewhere else, weirdo." They would
be and they would say, "Wow, that makes a lot of sense. Isn't
that how we change? >> That doesn't tell me why you're
morally correct and they're morally wrong." >> But it does
though, right? Like we are a society of different conversations
about different things. And I think most people are reasonable
regardless of whether or not. Do you understand? >> And
so that if I sit here, >> by the way, I could be wrong
about that. I don't study philosophy. >> I'm sure there's
some argument of like, oh well, that's different from making
sure you have to do your part to have a kid to carry on some
civilization. Would you debate Mr. or girl on that? Uh, maybe.
Maybe. But I'd have to think about it more. I just said that's
how I feel about it, right? He'll go hard on you for that. Um,
yeah, maybe
I I do think you have some some requirement to carry on society.
I think there's a limit to how far you could take the Yeah, anti
suck. I think there's a limit to how far you can um take that
in terms of what you could do to people, but I don't think um
13-year-olds having kids is the limit based on humanity surviving
up until this point when that was already a thing.
I I don't want to, by the way, I think that's a perfectly 13-year-olds
are not mature enough to have kids, to be mothers, right? Like
I I think that is a problem. It's just if there was a significant
enough pressure that that needed to happen, I do think you eventually
reach the point where you can let that happen. >> And I
say like, "Hey, listen. I think a 13-year-old is like would be
completely abused by an adult because they're not in the same
place at all. They're not physically as strong. They're not mentally
as strong." Uh that >> Do you have a worldview? No, not
really. >> Would I would imagine changed the minds of people
like it has historically. I >> Yeah. The the question is
if all of them said no. No. >> Oh, he muted himself on
Discord or sorry, not on Discord but on his stream. If all of
them think that abuse is fine, if all of them think that consent
is not required, if all of them believe that that's moral and
you're the only one who doesn't think it's immoral, what makes
you right and to the point where where becomes a moral? Probably.
But like
um consigning people to death is already a moral. No.
Like if if you're in a war, you do get drafted to defend your
country. It's already something that you have to do. Like this
is good. It's a moral good. You have to be drafted. You have
to go fight. You have to defend yourself, right? It's it's the
same argument you get to I remember a whatever podcast where
Far was arguing this with Andrew. It's like the same concept,
right? Like if aliens are invading, you don't just get to go,
"Well, we don't have any capacity. We don't need to continue
the race." No, you pick up the gun. Okay? It's space troopers
time or uh Starship Troopers time. Okay? It's Starship Troopers
time. You're a Marine. Here's your stim. Go.
>> All of them wrong. What makes you morally correct? and
they're all morally
That doesn't No, you didn't answer the question. You didn't answer
it. Well, here, let me let me show you what your >> You're
not You're not satisfied. Uh we're answer. >> Here's here's
what you said. I said, why is it that that would be the case
that you're morally correct and all them morally wrong? And you
said cuz I'd have a conversation with them. What does that mean?
What the [__] does that mean? >> What I what
I did is I laid out that 13-year-olds would be abused because
>> stimpacks are fallout poser.
Wait, what do you think the stim is in Starcraft? Marines Starcraft
stimpacks. You take a stimpack upgrade. >> They think abuse
is moral. They think it's moral. >> So then I guess I I
guess I would lose that conversation. That's usually how >> they're
wrong. >> Okay. I think I've answered this question multiple
times again. So I'm assuming that you are more focused on like
an objective morality where you say like, "Hey, the Bible >> focused
on trying to understand why they're [clears throat] all wrong.
That abuse of children is fine. >> They think it's fine.
They think it's moral. Why are they wrong morally and you're
right morally?" I've explained this like multiple times. You
don't The fact that you're not satisfied with my answer in answer
again. Use small words. >> The fact that you're not >> I
again you he's saying I was correct and it's like being correct
is obviously not in human history demonstrabably going to put
you in like the the cor the respected morally righteous camp.
Okay.
Is it Capernicus who got burned to death for saying the the Earth
revolves around the sun or that the Earth is not flat? One of
these one of these astronomers got burned to death. Okay, he
was right and he got burned to death. Okay,
Being correct is not an is not make you being scientifically
correct does not make you actually correct. Okay, >> a
satisfying answer is okay, but like I've already explained it.
Why don't we move on? Why don't you move on to what your world
view is? >> Explain it again. >> Okay. Well, I'm
not going to explain it like three times. So, >> you haven't
explained anything. >> Why don't you tell me why it is
that you're right and all and and moral and all of them are immoral.
Why don't you just move on to what your worldview is so we can
have a converting question,
>> Why? Why not just answer like you give me your perspective?
>> Stop coping and just answer the >> Okay. So, why
not just give me your perspective so I can understand better?
>> Okay. Here's my perspective. My perspective is that
it's in >> No, that's not true. That's I know that's not
true. >> For me to have to >> I just I never remember
the guy who got burned to death.
I can't remember it. Okay. Or got executed by the the Catholic
Church. or I don't even know if it's the Catholic Church. Plato
is not the guy that's Newton had the apple fall on his head and
I forget who drank
>> I found any sort of morality from a per
>> probably
who is the French guy Sartra. Probably the French guy seemed
like a
>> person who can't explain to me why it is that anything
I do is immoral.
>> Oh, Socrates. Okay. >> So, what's your morality
based on? >> Who cares? It's irrelevant. Can you tell me
why even if it was based in total lies, it would be immoral?
kind of just I'm I'm not I >> I think that I think that
like a pretty normal person would look at what I'm saying and
say like, "Oh yeah, we're a collection of different people with
different ideas and that's how our governmental structure."
>> How do you define normal? Andrew was literally off under
the table right now. Did this guy just invoke normality?
Yes. What's normal now? Oh, define normal. What's normal?
Yeah, >> that's been created and evolved over time. It's
irrelevant. And so like you disagree with that. That's okay.
So like where do you source your ideology from? Like is it very
religious? Sure. >> Okay. Cool. >> So [snorts] now,
now help me out here. If you can't tell me that anything that
I do is immoral without appealing to a consensus, and you say
as long as a consensus is on my side, then that means what I'm
doing is moral. Then that would mean that if I advocated for
the most horrific things in the world, i.e. essay
>> sexual assault, what would be the standard because of
YouTube, what would
>> Yeah. They may not censor things for you, but they censor
all kinds of things for me. But anyway,
>> yeah, I think Andrew is more concerned about um he's
saying essay cuz he he realized he's talking about ri cages for
people who don't want to have kids or whatever, right? And he
>> if he gets reported in trouble. >> Well, I mean
I don't know. I'm one of the most mass reported people out there
for no reason, but whatever. Okay. You would I mean you would
know. I wouldn't how would I know? It's just my channel. But
anyway. >> So true. Yeah. >> If they stuff them all
in in essay cages, right? >> Because that's [clears throat]
the consensus. Yeah. Can you tell me why that's immoral?
>> Yeah. I would take away someone's agency and autonomy
over themselves, which they should be able to have over themselves.
That's wrong. It's abusive and it's harmful and it's bad. >> Yeah.
But you see how that's a that's a
>> I think it's I think it's perfectly rational, reasonable,
and it's what we've been founding our entire structure on for
what since so like he's literally just saying it's good. It's
like or it's it's a it's you know uh he's not saying what good
is like he probably needs to go and then say well not just collective
good you have some individual right to determine your own future
right yeah autonomy
and that that belief comes downstream that's like our primary
belief as a consensus and then Andrew is going to argue okay
now now your right to autonomy doesn't matter anymore the draft
the draft right
all right and
It's basically like, okay, there's there is a consensus override
for your autonomy, your personal liberty.
Now, argue against the rib cages, I guess. So, I think it's fine.
>> It's bad cuz it's bad. >> Sure. If that's what
you got out of what I said. Sure. Yeah. >> That's what
That's what you said. It's >> If that's what you if that's
what you interpreted from what I >> do find it like kind
of annoying a little bit that Andrew has no compulsion to direct
the conversation somewhere that is going to resolve things that's
going to help. Like I do think at this point he's had this conversation
enough he should probably be able to quickly identify where somebody's
holes are in
as the guy advocating for SA. He could very quickly identify
that but where the holes are in their knowledge in in like the
gaps so that that he could fill those gaps in brutally. Okay.
So like it's just we're spending all this time sitting here like
embarrassing Papa Gut making him look like a It's like I think
you could tell what he doesn't understand. Some of the things
he doesn't understand it's like pretty obvious. No.
Why would Papa take this debate? Because he's been Andrew for
a long time and he looks like a when he like totally like he
Andrew Andrew's never harmed him and he constantly calls Andrew
like a and and says he advocates for and says he advocates for
a bunch of things he doesn't right.
And so Papa is like well I guess you know given you've never
done anything bad to me and I just constantly talk about you
I guess I should talk to you. And so he did it
right. We don't live in a Well, it's just the So, Papa Gut again,
the hypothetical for the cages could be literally like probably
not literally that, but the hypothetical for the cages could
be basically the human race is dying out for some reason. It's
like, okay, you you do come up with a hypothetical where those
make sense where like basically getting women to, you know, have
kids maximally for a certain period of time is like the thing
you have to do. You probably could come up with that hypothetical
and then what is the argument against that Handmaid's Tail? It
probably wouldn't be quite like handmade still either. Like realistically
with science, you probably make this a lot less horrible for
people than they do make it. >> Sure. Yeah. >> Well,
well, if the consensus is on my >> then what would make
us immoral and
>> I guess the cons I guess nothing, I >> Sure. Yeah.
>> So, if the answer is nothing, then you have no position
from which to critique. >> Then how then how is the way
you have no position to critique the morality of anybody ever?
So then how is my how is it that my position that I'm at that
I'm saying has been how we've been operating since like the start
of our country and
>> it isn't >> what is that >> the country
operated under a shared axiom of under God. >> the concept
of like the the
>> he already said the 13 just think of the 13-year-old
thing. You did live in a country that allowed 13-year-olds to
get married and have kids.
That was how your country was founded. That was okay in places
in your country. So like an >> that was the that was yeah
that was the shared aimatic presence >> that all of these
rights are justified because we ground them in something higher
than ourselves from your view all rights are justified because
you [__] like them and if the consensus says that
we don't like them anymore you don't have any grounding anymore
other
what do you think my religious ideology
>> I think that you're you're at least from the clip that
I saw >> uh I don't think you're religious at all. How
do you know I don't have a different relationship with God than
you do that's not as grounded inside of [snorts] religious text?
>> You I mean you you might but that doesn't mean that
it's coherent. >> I think it can be. I think a lot of the
Bible is uh God talking to different people mostly through feelings
and them feeling like hey this is better than that. And so like
yeah that's my relationship with God. I was >> God the
arbiter of morality. >> Sure. Yeah. I think so. I'd like
to think that. >> So you ground your morality in God. >> Yeah.
I think that there's a greater power out there. Absolutely. I
just think that the Bible has been taken advantage of by a lot
of different people [clears throat] to explain. >> So what
are the features? So what are the features of your God? >> I
have the same features as your God, except I guess mine doesn't
justify slavery. That's why I think that like the Bible justifying
slavery obviously isn't something that God would ever >> When
does the Bible justify slavery? >> In the Old Testament.
>> Inside the Old Testament. >> Oh, so you don't
you don't you don't know. I can help you with this if you >> Do
you feel like you need to? Well, I think you know it justifies
slavery. So why not be like, "Oh yeah, you know, here's here's
where you're wrong, though." Instead of >> I'm actually
willing to grant this. doesn't. But I'm actually willing to just
grant it. >> Well, it says you can be your slave for like
two days. As long as they don't die within two days, it does
justify >> Just for the sake of the conversation, I'll
just grant it for you. >> Okay. Well, it is in the Bible,
>> I think. Well, that's an ah historical view of it, but
fine. >> Well, that is what the Bible says, >> Yeah.
Where >> in the book of you just made it up? >> I
mean, you know, it says in the Bible that you can be your slave
and if it doesn't die in two days. >> Yeah. I mean, you're
not you're not exactly keen on context though. Otherwise, you
wouldn't make a piece of videos about me. So, >> what is
the context? >> Like, well, here I'll give you an >> Let's
pretend for a moment. >> Well, no. Why don't you just explain
the context to me? like we >> I'm going to I'll I'll explain
it, right? And here's how I'll explain it. >> I'm ready.
>> It's if it's the case that you have the option of eradicating
an enemy
>> eradicating them. >> Enslaving them by putting
them in like, I don't know, internment camps or things like this
or various camps in which you can have them under P conditions
or various things like this. Or you risk letting them go so that
they go back to the enemy and continue to aid them in fighting
against you. Which one would you choose? >> Is that the
context of of that? What about so how does that pair into intensity
inensure to servitude? Isn't that a lot of what the >> you're
looking you're looking through the lens of presantism. It's a
facious way to view the world didn't operate the same way. >> Well,
no, that's not not I'm not claiming. What I'm saying is you said
you made the claim that like every slave would have just run
back to some kind of an enemy. And I'm saying what about indentured
servitude? Countering that every slave would >> Yeah. How
[clears throat] Yeah. So I'm sorry. Did did indentured servitude
means you've sold yourself into it? >> So you have the
option to do that because you're a free person. >> No.
Oh, there's a whole conversation about like having financial
um agency and not having enough money to be able to survive and
having to do that. But that's not the point I'm trying to comply
with free will. That's what comply with free will. >> But
the point that I'm trying to make is that you're saying that
like every one of the slaves was some kind of an enemy. And I'm
just saying that's not the way that it has been. And I think
that's an >> Jeez, I'm sorry. I uh
I did the thing where you like swallow water wrong and die. And
I'm currently dying. So good luck with the good luck with this
conversation. It's running until I stop like coughing my brains
out and dying. Okay. It's an over exaggeration to try to make
it seem like it was >> You want to demonstrate it? You
want to demonstrate that? >> What does that mean? >> It
means show me that that's the case from a biblical view. >> Oh,
do you want to show me that that's the case from a biblical view?
>> It's it's your claim. >> Okay. So, you have just
as much claim as I do.
>> I don't know. You aren't showing me >> Why Why
do I need Why do I need to show you things about your claim?
>> I guess you don't. Yeah, >> I don't. Exactly.
Because it's your claim. You're You're the one who gets to give
me the evidence for the claim. The thing is here that's bizarre
to me is like under conditionals in which you can select for
P internmentment camps against the will of of people rather than
have them go back to the enemy. Would you select that?
>> I don't know. Maybe is that the entire context of all
of all this justification of slavery? >> Who cares? Just
answer the question first and then we'll talk about the
>> Answer the question of why. Well, we're talking about
the Bible. You're saying that in like >> it's the case
that you were in a war with another nation.
>> And it was a brutal war between your people group and
theirs [clears throat] >> and you were able you had three
options. Option one, you could exterminate them, civilians and
all. Option two, you can send them back to the enemy and that's
where they're going to go. They'll continue to aid them. Option
three, you can turn them against their will. Which would you
do? >> Well, we're not talking about interning them against
their will. We're talking about interning them and forcing them
to do labor. >> Yeah. So, what's wrong with prisoners doing
labor? >> Well, we're having we're talking about like slave
we're not talking about prisoners, though. We're talking about
like slaves, right? distinction between somebody who's interned
against their will and forced to do labor and a slave. >> So
you're saying that every single slave [clears throat] according
to the >> answer the question, dude. Stop avoiding
>> So So
an interned p forced to do labor. What's the difference? So you're
saying that every single >> super don't care about like
this specific I like the conversation. I'm good with the conversation.
I just mean I super don't care about >> like having this
the way they're having it right now. Hold on. Is this still working?
I think it's still going to work. Hold on. >> They've according
to the Bible question. You're saying you're saying X, just answer
the question. What's the difference between a >> and a
P forced to do work at some point? >> So, I just want to
be clear. What you're saying is that every slave in the Old Testament
was some kind of a P. >> I just want to be clear. I didn't
say anything like that. Now, answer question. So, >> why
not just give me a concise take? >> Answer the question.
>> Yeah. Well, you're proposing hypotheticals that don't
seem to actually related to religion.